this question was submitted by text by a
member of the Institute of Electrical
and Electronics Engineers the magnetics
community the question is what is the
future of semiconductors been Tronics
actually my feeling is that spintronics
with semiconductor with only
semiconductor maybe not the the most
promising with the most promising way of
spring tonic today first at the moment
there is no really a ferromagnetic
semiconductor working on hoon
temperature the higher temperatures have
been obtained with for gallium manganese
us a nice and wet and sympathy Kelvin
and so our hazard tres that the next
applications of semiconductor will be in
I win structure mixing conventional
semiconductor with ferromagnetic metals
for exams is begin to to be seen with
the estate a harms which the combined
magnetically junction with transistor
semiconductor transistor and with also
some projects where stt harms are
integrated on the top of in logic
architecture based on semiconductor is
new d'ivoire new concept of processor
and also so this generation of hybrid
sure can be an intermediate generation
between the electronics of today and the
electronic what is called beyonce Mossad
or beyond the electronic with silicon
and so an intermediate stage with the IV
structure or like for exams is stt harms
mixing tunnel junction magnetical
injunction and semiconductor and for the
beyond CMOS there are several candidates
to take the layoffs semiconductors seen
carbon-based molecular electronics but
also spinto newest carbon-based
materials specially with graphene or
carbon nanotubes the the main a
protector of this material they can
propagate spin currents too long
distances say yeah unheard of microns
and so is possible to conceive a
transport and treatment of information
based on pure spin currents not shotguns
ping koso new type of logic gate for
exam writing this new type of
informations and it's possible that this
will give rise to a electronic for
computer based on spin on a processor
for example